[Music]
years before Sam Ry ushered in the age
of the superhero with the Spider-Man
trilogy director James Cameron also had
New York's resident webslinger in his SS
sadly we never did get to see Leonardo
DiCaprio in the role of Peter Parker and
these are the reasons why James Cameron
Spiderman scriptment a long film
treatment with dialogue and Screen
Direction has become an artifact of
Hollywood Legend it obviously never made
it to the big screen but stanlee was
said to have loved it many elements of
the script which has been leaked and
even Illustrated online made it into the
Sam Ry directed film that ultimately saw
release in 2002 in Cameron's version
Peter wakes up not needing his glasses
loses Uncle Ben during a botched
carjacking and even has organic web
shooters rather than machines that
sounds exactly like the Toby Maguire
version and Cameron didn't get as much
as a thank you and the credits however
there's also Peter peeping in Mary
Jane's window while she gets dressed and
a scene where the couple gets intimate
on the Brooklyn Bridge as Peter
describes the creepy way that spiders
mate also Peter uses a intense profanity
throughout the story to the point that
it would have been completely
inappropriate for kids and most likely
are rated look at
little going to cry production never
Advanced far enough for a final
screenplay to be greenlet so it's
possible he could have been persuaded
away from the edge of your stop knowing
Cameron's history of stubbornness though
he likely would have wanted to make
Spider-Man his way or not at all James
Cameron is a wizard behind the camera
but in order for him to work his movie
Magic he needs to have a solid budget it
costs 100 $ million to make Terminator 2
and the director's movies only got more
ambitious from there Cameron Spider-Man
would have been a step back as he only
would have had $50 million to work with
turning an ordinary man into a wall
crawling hero isn't cheap after all Ramy
Spider-Man ended up costing $139 million
and its sequels only increased in scope
a mere 50 mils simply wouldn't have been
enough to bring Cameron's concepts for
villains Electro and Sandman to life in
a satisfying way nowadays massive
budgets are guaranteed when it comes to
both Spider-Man movies and films
directed by James Cameron Spider-Man no
way home took around $200 million to
make while estimates say that Avatar the
way of water required anywhere from $250
million to $400 million there were
consistent rumors that James Cameron
wanted to cast Arnold Schwarzenegger as
Doc O in his Spider-Man project and
given his history with the Austrian
strongman it's easy to believe
Schwarzenegger confirmed this in an
interview with Empire but only when as
far as to vaguely say the studio opted
for a different path Cameron script
doesn't even feature Auto Octavius so
it's hard to say how serious discussions
between the director and actor actually
got if they took place at all either way
Schwarzenegger's performance in Batman
and Robin showed that we're probably not
missing much Cameron had a few more
peculiar picks in his Dreamcast Edward
furong was supposed to be Peter Parker
but Leonardo DiCaprio also circled a
project and read an early screenplay
it's impossible to say for sure whether
or not furong or DiCaprio would have
done well in the role but it's hard to
imagine either of them matching Toby
Maguire's awkward charm there was also
Drew Barrymore as Gwen Stacy solid pick
and Arley hery from Full Metal Jacket as
J Jonah Jameson even better a drill
sergeant Jameson would have been
hilarious take on the character but it's
nearly impossible to beat the version of
the Brash editor and chief played by JK
Simmons I want that wall crawling ARA
that prosecuted I want him strung up by
his web while script casting and
budgeting issues all could have been
overcome what ultimately squash James
Cameron Spider-Man were legal problems
Cameron told collider that when
production company carollo pictures
collapsed which happened a few years
after they acquired the rights of
Spider-Man he already had Titanic in his
sights and no longer wanted to pursue
the project a number of former writers
and producers also claimed to have had a
hand in development and they all came
calling for their cut after Marvel's
1996 bankruptcy scattered multiple
holding deals to the wind when Marvel
recovered from bankruptcy they made
deals with everyone trying to sue for
the rights to Spider-Man allowing them
to be sold to Sony in 1999 Sony has
since gone on to make numerous
Spider-Man films in more than $2 billion
in franchise revenues and once Marvel
decided they wanted Spider-Man in the
MCU things got complicated all over
again don't feel bad for Cameron though
he turned one of the greatest Maritime
tragedies of all time into a billion
dooll Blockbuster he didn't get to adapt
his favorite comic book hero and might
have missed out on some spider cash but
he still did just fine no one can ever
accuse James Cameron of thinking small
especially when it comes to sequels
after all he created the Terminator
series expanding the universe of alien
and has long been hard at work on
multiple follow-ups to Avatar naturally
he didn't see a Spider-Man movie as
being a one-off feature as he revealed
to collider I got corco pictures to buy
Spider-Man I was going to launch that as
a series of films in the same interview
Cameron noted that Marvel's characters
were being misused by the studios of
that era he was correct after all comic
book movies still weren't in Vogue in
the early 99s despite the success of Tim
Burton's 1989 Batman film Marvel
properties lagged behind they are are
mostly confined to direct video or
television movies such as 1990s the
death of the Incredible Hulk and Captain
America Cameron saw an opportunity to do
more with the genre and its characters
an opportunity that Marvel would take
advantage of after the success of Iron
Man in 2008 as fans of Catwoman Deadpool
and Taskmaster can tell you firsthand
watching a filmmaker change an establish
Comics character for a screen adaptation
can be hugely frustrating with an
abundance of rich source material at
their fingertips it seems silly for
writers and directors to read invent the
wheel but the reality is that some
elements of superhero stories just don't
work outside of comics and animation at
least a few changes typically have to be
made and to get approval for certain
modifications Cameron personally
consulted Marvel Titan Stan Lee the
director told screen Crush I didn't make
a move without asking him permission so
what alterations did Lee apparently
approve of in Cameron's movie the spider
that bites Peter Parker wouldn't have
technically been radioactive instead
it's the result of an experiment
involving the transfer of DNA the
changes weren't limited to Spider-Man
himself as villains Electro and Sandman
have new names and backgrounds in
Cameron's script rather than Max Dylan
Electro is a ruthless businessman named
Carlton Strand and instead of Flint
Marco Sandman is simply called Boyd
instead of merging with nuclear sand
like the first comic version Cameron
Sandman would have had a similar origin
to the version of the character in
Spider-Man 3 you're kidding I fell into
a super collider
damn got to be careful where you fall in
a discussion with screen Crush Cameron
went into detail about his version of
Peter Parker who seems a lot like the
original character introduced in 1962's
Amazing Fantasy number 15 he stated the
first thing you've got to get your mind
around is it's not Spider-Man he goes by
Spider-Man but he's not Spider-Man he's
spider kid he's spider high school kid
he's kind of geeky and nobody notices
him and he's socially unpopular and all
that stuff the leag gripman does indeed
stress Parker's youth in awkward journey
through puberty there's even a scene
where he pops his zits in the mirror
before school acne aside Cameron stake
isn't too far from the version of Spidey
played by Tom Holland who was just 15
years old when he was first introduced
there's also the teenage Miles Morales
who has to deal with a world-ending
threat in his own changing body at the
same time in the spiderverse movies
that's weird my pant
shink I think I hit puberty Cameron
understood the key element of what makes
Spider-Man so compelling which Marvel
Studios now highlights he's still trying
to discover who he is as a person while
also coming to terms with his identity
as a super hero truthfully Spider-Man
fans have been blessed when it comes to
liveaction adaptations of his famous
costume while many debate which suit is
best no version has ever been terrible
not even Nicholas Hammond's outfit from
1977's The Amazing Spider-Man TV show
while a physical suit was never
developed for James Cameron Spider-Man
at least not that we know of the
filmmaker revealed concept art of his
vision in technoir the art of James
camon set in the nighttime his drawings
show Spidey in a Sleek costume climbing
up the side of the building as the
streets bustle below another version of
the concept image was also included
portraying Spider-Man in a much darker
outfit it's never explicitly named but
it looks an awful lot like the symbiote
suit that would later be popularized by
Ry Spider-Man 3 even though the TV show
Entourage takes place in an alternate
universe where James Cameron directed a
live-action Aquaman movie don't expect
to see the filmmaker attempting
something similar on our current Earth
Cameron was even critical of comic book
movies during a 2022 interview with the
New York Times saying that Marvel and DC
projects lack depth in the Trails of
Human Relationships there are many fans
who still hold out hope that Cameron
might change his tune if he's given full
control of his own project but nobody
should hold their breath as the Director
made clear to comicbook.com I have no
interest in directing a comic book film
I had an interest in Spider-Man but that
was a unique thing a personal love of
Spider-Man but that ground has been very
well served by other people
unfortunately it appears that James
Cameron's Spider-Man movie will remain a
Curious Case of what could have been
could we at least see a Leonardo deca
Spider-Man and Beyond the spiderverse
then probably not but never say never
there are infinite universes after
all